[Music]
uh
what's happening ball lickers now my
steakhouse up is a beautiful day to be
alive welcome to the church of what's
happening now joey diaz my main co-host
lee [ __ ] aka the flying jew what's
happening baby not much man how are you
doing you know me it's [ __ ] a
beautiful day to be alive it's wednesday
a lot of people don't like wednesday i'm
tired whatever [ __ ] you you just stayed
home smoke some dope and watch sons of
anarchy last night jack's got who the
[ __ ] gets married when the cops are
looking for you know what i'm saying
that's a brilliant move that's brilliant
because now he gets better visitation i
was going to say that yeah
yeah you get married right before you
[ __ ] turn yourself in i mean the
episode was great last night they've
been they were looking for brothers they
ended up finding a black guy [ __ ] a
white chick in the muffler
it was the [ __ ] bikers daughter the
guy got married [ __ ] uh
now you like that joke because i haven't
got into it and it's on netflix and i i
think yeah you know what man i said i've
said it before that i had friends on
that and my wife would watch it
sometimes and then katie seagal i mean
half of us grew up on kate as the guy
with married with children that was the
best show on [ __ ] tv 20 years ago
yeah i was in prison when that show
ended wow like when that show started
coming out i was locked up and i thought
it was just amazing i thought she was
hot like then she was kind of a big with
her [ __ ] head doing a little blonde
little [ __ ] nerdy looking boy and the
black belt jiu jitsu was on that's a
great show so it uh
it just but it's so weird when it's
becoming a lot of people don't see what
sons of anarchy is becoming
what a lot of people know is that
sopranos had a plan okay when the
sopranos first uh started the the deal
was it was going to end with the mother
running the family
but it didn't end that way she died
during the [ __ ] episode season two
okay in real life
so what's going on right now with this
is at the end you're gonna see it that
it's gonna be him and her running this
[ __ ] family this this uh sun's attic
but it's an interesting show you know
why bro because it's like what i like i
don't want to see the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
over and over again yeah at least these
guys are [ __ ] trying you know
i got a problem with [ __ ] fox but fx
is doing a phenomenal job is a bunch of
[ __ ] sheepy [ __ ] but fx somebody's
over there i think it's fox 21 over
there whatever they're really trying you
know when you watch sons of anarchy
they're saying [ __ ] and [ __ ] and they're
selling drugs and mexicans are getting
shot it was a great scene with jimmy
smith last night in the jacks where
they're getting chased okay and they and
jack says you know drop me off at the
corner [ __ ] jimmy smith's turn make
sure you turn and goes no let's go
straight at him i mean it's just a [ __ ]
is what it's supposed to be
balls to the wall on a [ __ ]
wednesday what'd you think of monday
night football i told you that uh that
game that that that game that was that's
what boredom was [ __ ] invented this
is football on monday it's tough this
country forgot you young [ __ ]
don't know what it was people didn't go
out on saturdays to go out on mondays
really yeah because it was huge i
couldn't wait to go on my we used to go
to ground round and then there were
clips and we would go in there and they
would have a happy hour on monday nights
ribs chicken wings you know [ __ ] like
that but anybody knows anger was down i
said like a ba that's what travolta's
from
but we go up there but i don't know
remember when we did the interview with
george and he was talking about the
place i used to dine and dash out of
yeah run around that was the place oh
jesus but we go at night for monday
night football and it was rock and they
put music people get a half gram of coke
you know one of their footballs was
rocking the old [ __ ] days yeah no it
was a it was it was a boring game but
uh
matt ryan looks really good he's a
falcons quarterback right he was great
and then peyton manning well this is the
thing about this [ __ ] country all of
a sudden when i was a kid growing up you
had to [ __ ] win six seven games and
get all [ __ ] excited now a
quarterback has a great weekend oh my
god it's the return what [ __ ] return
he won one [ __ ] game you know it's
the same thing happens in ufc some guy
has two good [ __ ] fights and awesome
oh
[ __ ] this guy he's got what what's wrong
with you
yeah what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
some guy wins two fights and this is
silver from winning fights is 2 000
[ __ ] won and people are still
doubting them but some guy wins two
fights one with a lucky punch and one by
submission against some guy that's
overweight or whatever oh no this he's
back to return get the [ __ ] out he's
gonna bang it off for six or seven
fights who's the guy who's had like 50
fights and he had the arrow with his
chest here
like the last couple fights he fought he
fought and two like two or three fights
ago and then the next card they brought
his name
he's a he's a guy who i think you'd like
because he he's fought like 50 times
he's never been the champion but he
always fights hard and he's had like 50
professional fights so it's a it's a
difference between a guy like that who's
been solid in the ufc like 40 or 50
times and uh the guy who i don't really
like uh what's uh benson henderson he's
like the champion right now right right
i don't really like him he's fighting uh
diaz in november i think via is gonna
[ __ ] line them up but there's a ufc
fight
this week oh yeah john jones against
[ __ ] veto belfor
and people been hitting me up already
what are your picks it's [ __ ]
wednesday yeah it's [ __ ] wednesday i
don't know i want to see the weigh-in i
want to see that look on the face so
it's very tough to give a pic
right now with the fight i like this
weekend the best i mean one thing about
the fight card this weekend is that
they've got it's a tendency against uh
uh whatever veto that's a great fight
but the [ __ ] cards got some bankers i
don't have time to go into this because
we only have an hour but between you and
i the fight i like this week is [ __ ]
better videos against uh little johnson
but that's going to be a hell of a
[ __ ] bank
two guys these two guys are going to
throw punches at each other from from
all angles you know you don't wear 3d
glasses and don't get stoned because
this is a fighter [ __ ] speed this
[ __ ] is going to
be going in out in out and out punches
kicks and that benavides kid is [ __ ]
solid he can anyway i like i like joe
benavides so far that's what i'm going
with so far everything else is
background is like i said there's no
reason to sit here and tell you eight
[ __ ] pics because nobody's gonna hit
him anywhere get one pick blast it like
you [ __ ] own it and go for it you've
[ __ ] sucker anyway what's going on over
there it's a beautiful day to [ __ ] be
alive i'm not smoking on air no more i'm
stuck getting stoned in the morning and
i'm also not eating those edibles lee i
was getting too [ __ ] up oh you know by
12 o'clock that other boy [ __ ] six in
the morning's ruining my [ __ ] day
exactly like i come in and you want me
to do the chocolate i'm like i don't
know but it's your day off one little
piece like sunday we're doing a special
beauty to be sunday and that's when
we'll [ __ ] get blasted off because
what are you doing though i'll do it on
sunday but you want me to do it four
hours before i go another little piece
you get the wings
i need a whole [ __ ] bar oh i don't
know how you're selling live no i eat
the whole [ __ ] bar so by 12 o'clock
i'm walking around thinking because it's
like by 12 o'clock you're feeling like
uh you're either gonna have the diabetes
is kicking in
and yeah yeah it's [ __ ] amazing you
don't know what i was walking around i
found myself on lancashire
i don't know how you find yourself
walking around on that i can barely find
myself moving from when i when i get
high the first thing i get like 10 years
ago you know for years i love getting
high and working out nothing better than
[ __ ] smoking a half a number putting
the [ __ ] well i started with the
[ __ ] walkman now it's an ipod putting
your speakers in and going to the gym
and just letting it all hang out if
you're your own personal [ __ ] gym i
got the kennel next door if you got your
own personal [ __ ] gym you just go
blast you know whatever music you listen
to and start [ __ ] lifting and stuff
like you know you forget i get so into
the workout when i get high and i go
down there forget when you eat an edible
like i like eating available monday
mornings because i'm tuned up by the
time i get to yoga at 11 30. yoga was
meant to do with a [ __ ] edible inside
i'm over there stretching i'm doing yeah
my style i just gotta ask you because
i'm doing downward [ __ ] dogs to
stretch when you feel the stretch and
then she says breathe into the stretch
if you're a little high you're more
conscious of it you're looking the other
way i focus on my breathing because i
have a hard time [ __ ] breathing you
can hear it on the mic that's why i say
hello to mike they think some [ __ ]
guy is coming out or whatever
but uh i love it but i can't do it
number one besides you know what [ __ ]
pissed me off that
i've been eating bang chocolate and
talking about bang for a long [ __ ]
time they make a great product guys yeah
they really do i like the uh the cookies
and cream i like the fly at three string
and don't get me wrong there's stuff
that's stronger out there
yeah that stuff doesn't kill that but i
like the taste of that chocolate it's
fine chocolate they do a good job with
it it's low on points if you eat like
one strip it's like three points or a
weight watchers but here's where it
[ __ ] kills me that i've been putting
it on you know listen guys i ain't
looking for a dick from nobody as you
[ __ ] know i don't time waits
for nobody you know me and we put a cd
together we do the testing with
testaments i don't wait for a record
label i don't got no mind [ __ ] either
you're on the program in my life or you
don't that's part of the church or
what's happening now this is our
[ __ ] playing field i come here
for months we go on [ __ ] uh podcasts
we talk about you know i go on 30
million podcasts i talk about weed this
that and edibles you know i i twit them
i reached out to them a couple days away
bang we show your thing you know send us
some [ __ ] love say support church or
what's happening now send the t-shirt
send me two free chocolates i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm still gonna go buy your
product these [ __ ] on twitter
acting like you know their [ __ ] don't
stink they don't return nothing then i
went yesterday to divine wellness to get
the chocolate bar and i asked the guy
did he come here with the cookies and
cream guy goes no he hasn't returned our
call hasn't done nothing so i go you
know what these [ __ ] suck [ __ ]
from head to toe
listen
you know uh
me and lee were discussing something
before i didn't want to bust it out
early but i'm gonna go into a little bit
you know everybody's waiting for obama
and [ __ ] romney or jesus or [ __ ]
mormon god what the [ __ ] your god is to
save the world
that's not going to save the world
character is going to save this
[ __ ] you know this guy was
telling me i said he's called bang 10
times
and they haven't returned his calls or
[ __ ] even brought any more chocolate
down that's number one number two the
[ __ ] guy i've emailed him i read his
[ __ ] i've tweeted him like twice told
him about bang how i loved it they don't
even have the [ __ ] so if you listen
over a bang go [ __ ] your mother i'll
never [ __ ] put bang chocolate up here
again you miserable [ __ ] show
some [ __ ] respect because in this
world listen these [ __ ] i had a
situation yesterday where i've been
talking to some guy and i've been
calling him because i call people i
don't have time to be texting people
hiding behind some [ __ ] phone i call
people the [ __ ] didn't show up
to the meeting and two hours later he
texts me nothing pisses me more than
that [ __ ] call me at least the guy texts
me i ain't mad at that it's these dumb
[ __ ] who you leave a message
for and they don't find the time to call
you back especially when you're doing
them a favor or whatever you know what
have some [ __ ] balls somebody calls
you pick up the phone and call them the
[ __ ] back let them know you're in the
area but there's a lot of [ __ ]
especially in hollywood in this area
here who thinks that i don't i've never
understood who think they think their
[ __ ] time is more important than your
[ __ ] time and nobody's time is more
important than your time if you treat it
that way if you don't treat it that way
then that's what people are going to do
you know what somebody [ __ ] calls you
call them the [ __ ] back but these
[ __ ] don't even call the weed
store back a place that sells they're up
there wherever the [ __ ] they are walking
around with sandals on looking at high
times
hey dude
dumb [ __ ] call back bang we
need your [ __ ] chocolate you [ __ ]
douchebag or twit me you [ __ ] [ __ ]
suckers it's too early for this shitley
lee let's talk about the [ __ ] arm of
the week because i gotta drop this on
people because people don't know
yesterday it was jimi hendrix's 42nd
uh birthday or whatever his anniversary
was dead okay
and
you know i played that i played [ __ ]
sound garden i love pearl jam i like all
this [ __ ] and it's funny that people
understand you know i got so deep into
the coat
after
85 and 86 i don't even buy [ __ ] new
music i remember bits and pieces of
history like i remember pouring some
sugar on me from 87 and uh you uh you
two whatever
bullet for blue skies whatever the
joshua tree which was a brilliant album
i remember bits and pieces don't ask me
who won the the championships in 87 or
you know who won baseball in 89 i have
no idea i blacked out i was just on
drugs i was on another trip you know
sometimes you head somewhere else
and i [ __ ] uh was dead basically and
for some reason
in 94 i was living in boulder i was
living in north boulder across the north
boulder recreation center that's to keep
myself in shape
and i was walking i said i heard these
guys
had to be like 17 you know i'm probably
30 or something i see these guys
listening to this music
and they're banging their [ __ ] heads
right i'm like look at these [ __ ]
momos
this is our future right here right
but what they would listen to was so
[ __ ] unreal that after like 10
minutes i had to walk to these idiots
and go listen
not for nothing guys what the [ __ ] is
this yeah and they showed me the album
cover and i uh
listened to the name of the band and
that afternoon after i worked out i took
my [ __ ] bike and i went over to
whatever record store i was going to
boulder at the time sorry people
and i walked in i bought this album and
i brought it home and after three songs
i had to get up put the album down the
cassette whatever the [ __ ] i had bought
yeah the cd it was and uh i he'll get a
bag of weed
and come back and start from the
beginning because he didn't move me so
[ __ ] jesus
i like this style of music so much and
if you look at me you can't tell i love
grunge
i love it i love it i live in seattle
yeah i loved everything and i was an old
man when i lived up there considering
what was going on
but i loved the whole thing about it i
loved [ __ ] when i heard pearl jam i
lost my mind but the album that pushed
me was now called bad motor finger by
sound garden it is one of the great and
it opens up with rusty cage i know right
away 200 of you momos are going to say
listen to the johnny cashman listen you
dumb [ __ ] if i wanted the
johnny cashmere i'm gonna put on the
johnny cash one so when i put on music
don't hit me with what about the cover
from faith no more suck my dick i don't
want to hear fake [ __ ] no more i want
to hear it by sabbath that's why i'm
[ __ ] playing it but the funny thing
is
this um guy now destroyed me like i sat
there for two hours smoking dope rolling
joints and crying
when i listen to music and i cry that
means i'm just and then i put on you
know then after that didn't stop then
alice in chains and that's another band
up there there were like four bands up
there that were throwing [ __ ] heat
and i moved to seattle
and i go to those club giggles in the u
district okay it was run at the time by
a vietnam vet that uh
that uh uh he was a pilot and he got hit
in the head with a [ __ ] missile or
something and he would lose his memory
so i would work all weekend right yeah i
would call him bob or something was his
name i'd call him on monday and go bob
who's the feature act this weekend and
he would say nobody i go can i feed you
and he'd go yeah show up thursday to
tacoma or forget what the thursday night
gig was on friday and saturday you're in
seattle okay the view district so i
would work but i knew the wages are so
good that sunday nights i would ask
saturday nights i would ask the waitress
call back there and see who's featuring
next week and they would come back and
go nobody and monday 901 i would call
bob and go mom who's featuring this week
who's this joey diaz
uh why you want a feature yeah when was
the last time you were at the club he'd
ask me oh i'd say nine years ago right
all right see you thursday i would do
this three weeks in a row and he would
never remember but the best was you know
the mind of joey diaz i'm always [ __ ]
criminalizing you know
i would go in on thursdays and ask him
for a draw
okay
on thursday and then by saturday he
forgets
and then i call him again on monday go
hey [ __ ] who's there on this
weekend nobody when was the last time
you were at the club 18 [ __ ] years
ago see you thursday that's hilarious
there was a waitress there a little
white dirty [ __ ] thing that i loved
she was just i never fooled around well
never [ __ ] on them we were just tight
we'd smoke joints together uh-huh she
had the blonde streaks on the hair real
[ __ ] petite dirty feet like i like
them little tits no bra the bra smell
like [ __ ] ginger snaps
got that pachugi juice their [ __ ]
monkeys probably smell like [ __ ] juice
and petchuki juice meats with a little
chinese [ __ ] dolly you know
it's tremendous that little noodle
smells like that little way like when
you lick the noodles sometimes you got
that that glazed on pee like it's like
glazed onions caramelized onions you
never eat that [ __ ] well it's got that
little [ __ ] i never liked it before
oh it's got a little baby piece smell to
that little clip it just pops open like
a [ __ ] soldier anyway
she would always tell me anyway if you
wanna get [ __ ] up come with me to
queen anne hill
and i would go what are you talking
about she's like the people from alice
in chains the band the singer has a
house and a bunch of people go in there
and they do [ __ ] h and i'll tell you
what guys god did me a favor when he put
me on this planet he made me not like
[ __ ] needles
because if you go to a guy that shoot
nature and you go to the house and tell
him you know uh uh you know i'm smoking
i'm i'm gonna snort it they'll look at
you like you know me
somebody come and hear me going hey
let's do a bunga and they're like no i
just want to vaporize my lungs i'll
smack you so that's you can't when it
comes to heroin you can't be playing
with these people like hey uh you know
i'm gonna come up here and do a line so
i never went up there with this girl
trust me i want to do anything to rape
this [ __ ] girl she was beautiful she
would be i would love to freak out with
on an age you don't know what it's like
a little sex like a [ __ ] h your dick
gets all hard where you get a little
feather and tickle her [ __ ] forget
about your nod you're drooling everyone
looks like i could never mess up it's
tremendous i just i'm telling you i'm
scared of it you know it was like i did
it that's how i got off blowing
uh five years ago that's a different
[ __ ] story but it's funny i would
never go up there and i asked one day
who's this band
and she's like alice in [ __ ]
chains
and i'm like are you [ __ ] serious
and and then i went home and i got some
album by them the first time
and i nearly [ __ ] freaked out i i
wasn't dirt it was something else i
forget the [ __ ]
call coming in
do it baby
yo
yo who's this
martin perez oh [ __ ] martin we were
talking about something but let me give
them a little insight into who the [ __ ]
martin perez is when i first moved to
north berlin i lived downtown and given
that terrorist my mother had a bar in
union city
and one of the guys she hung out with
his name was machito and he had a kid
named julie and a cousin it was martin
perez and uh me and martin became
friends and we'd [ __ ] around i mean this
is somebody that i met in the sixth
grade in mr lovrito's class he had the
wig then correct
the what the wig lovito had the wig
right in the sixth grade already
you know i just talked to [ __ ] lavito
a couple weeks ago he was at mario arias
in las vegas
mario and uh oh uh what was this guy's
name for zalavar louis zaldavar was his
name
louis zaldivar and mario on the pilot
program in the sixth grade correct they
were like 16 in the sixth grade they had
the mustache the beard they drove their
kid to school and then they came
upstairs
in north bergen right martin they had
the uh
followers south of all were stronger
bro i seen him smack leo tony one day
the principal he smacked them downstairs
in the [ __ ] basement
that's the way we lit the the the
all the bathrooms on fire and we got
suspended
was the one that sneaked on us mckinley
peter me and petey jimmy has had to do
uh
this uh that's right we call this thing
for arsene we had to go like for a month
every day and i used to ride my little
mini bike to
this arsenal thing what kind of mini
bike did you have did you have a little
honda trail like me or did you have one
of the ghetto ones that you had the
lawnmower
no i had come on man i had the yamaha
80. oh [ __ ] that's right we all were
little [ __ ] bikers remember we used
to go down and uh rob the trains did you
go down that mountain and rob the trains
by seaworkers
yeah the ones we robbed them
they re like a wanda and all that [ __ ]
remember they used to shoot us with
they weren't built remember they were in
a box they were small bikes like that
not that you had to build them the gas
tank was off the seat was off so you had
to put all this [ __ ] on once you got on
yeah open up the carburetor in those
days and remember they used to shoot us
with salt and pepper guns down there
you ever get shot with a sword type of
gun i still got my scar on the side
and that that sure burns like a
[ __ ] bro it's like rotten [ __ ]
juicing eyeball you know what i'm saying
a gun with like salt yeah with the cubes
and when they hit you they blow up
something happen you scratch like a
[ __ ] martin tell these people
who your father was and what you
remember from these times brother
oh my father was a colonel in cuba
second chief of police of batista
and uh
he was a real real strict guy
unfortunately i was born i was raised in
jersey and
you know he couldn't he couldn't keep a
good eye on me all the time so he got
into a lot of mischief
and he will always sell
well
a real
you know strict that my
my mother's side of the family was kind
of wild
my cheeto yo yo that was the front of
your mom's gogo machito your uncle
yeah
and
when they used to go to the bar and what
i said
what what what did we call a
middle-class gangster yeah yeah we we
were we were middle-class [ __ ]
gangsters i one day i was sitting there
writing the one of the testicle
testaments i wanted a
somebody other than myself to describe
my stepdad juan
and i had the only person allowed so i
called martin and i go one martin if you
had described one how would you describe
him
scary
scary [ __ ]
he was he was a real you know
you know very very hardcore guy
i don't know if you want me to tell him
what he did for him no you can tell him
i don't give a [ __ ]
the [ __ ] guy was a hitman
i mean it was amazing you know they had
an article the other day by jose battle
in the [ __ ] uh and then somebody on
twitter hit me up again do you know who
jose battle was martin
or say backwards
battle was a guy that fought for he went
down with with the united states the cia
to to cuba for the bay of pigs and when
all that [ __ ] went down he got pissed
off when they let him out of jail he
told the [ __ ] cia that he didn't care
about him wasn't mad at them he just
wanted to do his own thing for 10 years
so he ended up becoming one of the
biggest [ __ ] bookmakers and [ __ ]
and he lived in west new york
so that's how all those people nico and
[ __ ] one and all that [ __ ] but i
wanted to tell a story with you martin
real quick about uh when we we did two
things i really remember about martin
that we laughed our asses off in the
sixth grade where one uh people used to
put glue on trees on the wall and you
light your the fire on the glue then you
blow it out and the [ __ ] your
initials were on the wall right this is
what was big that and uh on 26th street
projects where i used to hang out martin
used to live down there which was
a tremendous [ __ ] place tremendous
uh there was a tree and one night me and
martin and his cousin went and bought
the [ __ ] glue and we were gonna you
know put it on the tree and
me and julie did it and when it was
martin's turn
he put his initials on the mp and he lit
it on fire but some glue or something
hit a leaf
and it could only happen to martin right
so here for two months everybody's been
uh writing their initials nobody gets in
trouble next thing you know the tree is
on fire and martin is blowing on it
that's what i remember you blowing out
of me going why are you blind at least
and all of a sudden out of the corner
just like a golf cart coming with
[ __ ] three or four cars
and
uh with three or four guards on it and
they went to the rest of them
so this yeah they took me away they took
away his cousin with downstairs howard
oh jesus howling with downstairs
and how about that how about the time
that julie
julian was my cousin he was like two
years younger than me was yeah yeah
three years younger because he was two
years younger than me
he looked exactly like me so he beat up
a little kid that was his age
i don't know if you remember that
he beat up a kid that was his age and
the little kid thought it was me and he
came into my house and said i was in he
beat me up he beat me up well i didn't
beat you up and goes yeah yeah you beat
me up and my father was ready to kick my
ass for beating up on somebody left
you know underage until right when my
father had the belt of my and his hands
in the air ready to beat the [ __ ] out of
me julian comes out and goes oh it was
me
so you're right
hey talk to these guys about mckinley
about mr king well how many meetings did
mr king will get the seventh grade
teacher from students
i remember what i remember about king
well what he was a seventh grade teacher
when we walked into that we
used to go in the day before the day the
last day of school you used to go to
your next
year's class
so this is the first day i ever go to
his class and he's he's standing in the
front of the door saying you're going to
fail
you're going to fail you're going to
fail remember that coco yeah yeah he
used to poke you in the [ __ ] here and
punch in the ribs like give you a little
top [ __ ] jesus and now whose sister beat
him up your sister
your sister my sister
my sister
he slapped the [ __ ] out of me one day my
sister goes over there and go my
sister's like
half his size and poking on his stomach
and telling him what the [ __ ] me hit me
you're lucky my father doesn't come over
here the [ __ ] out of you now were you in
the class when he hit one of the carver
house and mr carvajal now to describe
the cavalhouse maria is on facebook it's
beautiful
they were all like chunks the whole
family they called the one son the beast
he's a trump driver he's bigger than a
truck now but the father was gigantic
and he was from the we what were the
cubans called wajido right or wrong
where their country [ __ ] okay
but those are the ones that will kill
you and he used to wear his little
shirt with a [ __ ] cigar that looked
like a baton
his cigar looked like a baton in front
of 26th street and i guess one day
unbelievable unbelievable one day
[ __ ] he hit one of his kids and at
three o'clock that day you heard
and they're like open up and it was mr
carbohog mr king looks and he goes i'm
gonna do to jew
what you do to my son and he smacked the
[ __ ] out of him mckinley was crazy man
and remember who replied
you had left already but you know that
the guys that replaced uh mr lindsay
wally lindsley repeat replaced
uh like uh what was the ethel welsh and
miss verga right with the eighth grade
teacher oh my god
and ethel walsh was
we required them beating them too late
we retired she kept saying i'll be here
after you come and go uh ethel welsh
were retired and miss virgas uh retired
first not though wallace we tortured but
the guy that replaced
miss verga his name was wally linsley he
was the mayor of weehawken but he was
also a school teacher in north bergen
and he's the one that sold the
waterfront out in hudson county there so
they erect the atf arrested them in the
eighth grade
think about being in your [ __ ] class
sitting in the school and also the
[ __ ] atf shows up and takes your
[ __ ] school teaching jesus that's the
school we [ __ ] grew up man what did
you leave
how about that that guy remember when we
were in uh in pe or joey the coco
i'm sorry
i don't remember the guys of uh uh named
his father came in with his his
mafia
and told the principal i want to see
that i want to see the the uh
the pe teacher i want to see the pigs
teacher no no no we can't what was the
guy's name carmine bowzano
anthony
so torah pushed me you and anthony
balzano for speaking spanish
and anthony stuck up for us he's like i
don't give a [ __ ] you can't tell these
guys what to do and not to speak and
this teacher hauls off and starts
hitting us but he pulled mine in
martin's heads and he banged them like
when we went upstairs we were going
through our hair and there was hair on
the sheet so when carmine came in he got
caught you know right away anthony's
like dad let me tell you what happened
he didn't let these guys talk spanish
[ __ ] that it's a free country but he's
like financially you're italian so what
you got to stick up for spanx you know
what i'm saying
and the next thing you know this [ __ ]
guy went into that principal's office
and was the was that [ __ ] teacher
there the next day hell no
they transferred to toronto no he was
gone and goku when we counterfeited the
lunch tickets
oh yeah we were kind of that one oh [ __ ]
because i forget all this [ __ ] dog this
is how much
we sold more counterfeit tickets than
the school did
no this is [ __ ] classic
though
12 year old counterfeiters 12 year old
[ __ ] counterfeiters we used to
deliver pay everything that hold all
those neighborhoods were never safe with
us we were always trying to flip a buck
you've been doing your whole life we
were kids that were always trying to
flip a buck man there's no [ __ ] game
playing game boy and all that [ __ ]
we lived it though we didn't have time
to watch a tv and steal a car in my mind
we lived it [ __ ] little momos today
let's go play [ __ ] game boy you live
it [ __ ]
got money
hey joe when we used to take the orders
from people give me your order for lunch
give me order for lunch and then get hey
jose had title to go steal it from
something from uh shop right shop right
he'd go to the shop right and take all
our orders and just pack in a brown bag
he'd walk down the aisle just putting it
into it
hey did you go with us to to do our
confirmation coco no i got thrown out of
uh
place in union city saying not saying
michaels but the other one not saint
rocco but there was another one where i
went like two or three times and one of
you guys asked the [ __ ] priest
uh who wrote the bible and was it real
and how did we know that this [ __ ] was
real he threw a bunch of us out you
don't remember we got to go to we had to
go to co i remember
and then it was me
uh dean lapree john bender vanessa q
like 20 of us
we used to go to blimpy smoke dope and
then go to [ __ ] in the seventh grade
we go to blimpy smoke dope and then go
to community destruction so if you ain't
topping that one kids go [ __ ] yourself
your father listen in the confirmation
at the end i don't know if you went but
we changed all our names our last names
ourselves like
dean le prick martin protest
john fender and this is the priest the
preacher
the priest and on our confirmation
saying all these names and we were
rolling in the middle
i gave them the [ __ ] voices they gave
the wrong [ __ ] names man
now this was uh martin i'm happy you
called cause you had come to my house
swimming at the pool
you had come to my house
i mean you were around for years with me
we used to go to the movies together i
used to go to 7th street and watch
martin do judo class remember martin
dominance
remember
her son la lupe and her son la lupe is a
cuban performer that's on youtube that
while she would sing she would rip her
[ __ ] clothes off who would not even
pink doing somersaults could do that
[ __ ] this cuban lady used to rip her
[ __ ] clothes i can't remember you i
can't believe you strumming my loop at
my house
yeah larupa used to go to our your house
too right yeah yeah all the time i used
to watch i'm changing [ __ ] she had a
skinny [ __ ] i remember i was a young
kid her [ __ ] was skinny
a little hair looked like uh like eddie
monster a little [ __ ] here
was scraggly martin hey what was like
dave everybody was well you were banging
big time when
she was like a cousin of yours or
something oh i banged all my cousins you
know me no she wasn't the cousin see my
mother had baptized the eevee from the
bronx the puerto rican girl
yeah she taught me how to eat [ __ ] a
little nasty [ __ ]
i remember the first time i ate a monk i
didn't even have hair or nothing evie i
forgot all about it evie i had evie and
i had the other puerto rican that my
mother my mother would baptize all these
kids she'd be their godmother and they'd
have to spend the week with us or
something okay after the third night i'd
because i think in the cuban yeah that's
very big being the guy it's bigger the
catholic religion being a godparent you
know
martino i love you all my heart for
calling bro anything you want to say at
the end
i just want to say coco i love you
brother you're always my brother no no
no
i didn't see martin for 20 years and he
showed up at the miami improv and he
gave me a hug and i almost
[ __ ] died so we've got this bro i'm
49 years old martin how old are you
50 50. so we've been [ __ ] 11 years
old with 13 and 12 and 11
with peter jimenez and we used to walk
up and down that hill and what about the
[ __ ] riots against united city
throwing eggs
the projects oh remember the
the
day before uh halloween the mixed devils
from union city to [ __ ] jersey city
those little stinkies they don't stop
dog
remember we used to go and glue the the
pennies on the
we were bad but remember we used to
throw them we used to go to dura test
and throw light bulbs at people and the
[ __ ] light bulb remember that with
the irregular light bulbs you're
throwing light bulbs in here yeah they
made all light bulbs and beams you know
those long tubes so i would come up to
you with one of those things and hit you
and the thing would just blow up and
white powder would go in your face and
[ __ ] oh my god and then we used to have
remember the bananas
cavahar was the one that threw an apple
through
the jewish temple thing
and then they said it was a brick and
they put them in prison and then they
put them in jail and everything
yeah he got caught by he was robbing
trains wasn't he
and his arm yeah he got
he got he got electrocuted yeah he
that's the last time i went down there
once somebody gets elected the party's
over
they get them
i forget what his name was he's driving
a cab now
yeah and you remember lewis the the the
the crippled guy on the bottom of us
and we used to take him into it uh uh
man that was [ __ ] up that'd be slow
you remember w slow that'd be slow we
used to have a lot of crazy people in
that neighborhood i gotta run uh my
thesis they get them in my life
i'll call you next week
bye bye
that's [ __ ] nuts huh now for people
my age and he brought it up but i didn't
want to stop you guys talking explain
who bautista is because it's a story
that i don't think people like people my
age would understand batista was the guy
who was running cuba before fidel that's
who fidel won and succeeded it was a guy
batista frugio batista and
in reality batista was a bad
[ __ ] i mean because
yeah and on one hand he had cuba it was
it was booming i mean all the stories
you hear about cuba is when batista was
running that [ __ ] but on the
other hand he was
the the poverty was at [ __ ]
tremendous levels he was robbing his
people he was worse than communist in a
way because he was shaken down to live
so when batista got knocked out of that
batista got had to go in exile because
[ __ ] cubans don't [ __ ] around they
don't forget nothing they forgive for a
little while but don't go get them you
know so i i don't know what the whole
thing was batista but a lot of people
like batista and a lot of people were
[ __ ] against batista and at the end
when fidel came in he brought a promise
fidel lied to the cuban people he
brought in a promise that he was going
to change things and look he was a tommy
so so but my point was so his father was
like a general or very high up in his
army very happy so the people around you
i can't even imagine how how strict his
father would be and then there's your
father and it's just
martin's father was a no-nonsense guy
whenever he said martin
everything stopped he was big you know
what what made me think of martin was i
was at eddie bravo's house
and i watched uh uh a [ __ ] video
about cuba that he had with batista
there and i seen martin perez standing
next to him he looked just like martin
who i had on the phone yeah and i go
look i gotta call martin because they
talked to martin a lot i thought you
know we thought he has a big company in
florida i mean uh
he's down there
[ __ ] making it happen but i'm just
happy that we're still talk i mean how
lucky am i yeah you know he's one of the
few people left from that side of my
life
from that side of my life the life
before my mother died that could vouch
for me in any situation there's maybe
three or four yeah and that's why i
honor this guy so much and i and i i
believe all your stories i don't like i
never in my head think you're lying
but
you know i have stories from my
childhood that are um
kind of uh they they grow over the years
and i couldn't imagine out 12 stealing
motorcycles off of a train and he called
and he brings it up
and i get like he's throwing bikes off
of a train listen uh
first off i had nothing to lose so you
know i had nothing going on in my comedy
career i had nothing i was doing sets
yeah i was doing movies and my name is
earl and people were impressed or
whatever but
i didn't know what was going on and i
started doing a podcast with felicia and
i started telling stories about my life
man you know a lot of them you forget
they're so [ __ ] terrible a lot of
them you forget i'm not gonna lie to you
you don't want them you don't want
nobody to know
and i started saying them and you know
what i would show up to [ __ ] these
shows and people be all around going dog
tell us that story again do this like oh
you [ __ ] people can't you know i
always thought everybody had stories
yeah that's why i didn't want to tell
nobody some of them i can't say listen i
got 800 stories
300 of them i can't [ __ ] tell you you
know what i'm saying because it's just
not right and you'll hear them as they
go along because people are going to
call and slip or whatever
but uh
i got no reason to lie i'm the real
[ __ ] exactly i'm the real [ __ ]
deal and this is just
uh i sit here sometime like i said i
thought everybody lived the life i
thought everybody went and robbed trains
when they were 12. and these are middle
these were middle uh what do you call
that middle class middle class kids
these were middle class kids that hung
out at projects to hang out with the
other kids that didn't have so much you
know what i'm saying we didn't judge
there was no judging we knew who to hang
with who rocked who had your [ __ ]
back in those days yeah not like these
[ __ ] momos with a skateboard going
what the [ __ ] you know after school some
of the kids had money some didn't we
would walk a mile to the [ __ ]
meadowlands where the meadowlands are
now uh and there'd be trains out there
by seahawks they really like a water and
the trains would go by and we would
position ourselves and you'd have to
jump on the train and break the [ __ ]
seal and then open the door and then get
in there there were 12. was the train
moving the train was moving on a slower
pace
jesus christ the cops would be driving
the the knocked up the regular cops but
to try you know transit station amtrak i
don't even know if it was amtrak then
yeah
so you had to take the boxes throw them
off the [ __ ] trains hide them in the
weeds like sons of anarchy in the
episode last week with the guns and then
have
walk back to north bergen eat dinner
pray that nobody steals your stash and
then get one of your older brothers or
one of his friends you got to pay him 50
bucks you're 12. so that means you got
to say listen dawg i have six
motorcycles let me log them back once i
sell two of them i'll throw you a
[ __ ] half a yard 100 we were 12. wow
and that's that's something when he was
talking it made me realize when you were
talking about selling the lunch tickets
and then going before church going to
blunt bees to get a sandwich and then
smoke you really haven't changed that
much throughout your life no you i mean
you grow up and you mature a little bit
but you're doing the same stuff listen
man all you do is is rub out the edges
and make them not as sharp that's all
you do but you are who the [ __ ] you are
i am who the [ __ ] i am
you know in those days the deal wasn't
fun let me tell you let me bring it down
more on fridays
if you didn't want to go to school in
the afternoons you either had to go to
school or you had to go to catholic
community education ccd i don't know
what they called it they still have it
so you had to be there at one so
basically you would go to school from
nine to twelve some of the pimps
would sign up and go to ccd and the
other ones would stay in because we had
leviton so on fridays mr levito at one
o'clock since half the kids were gone he
would put a record play on
and you were allowed to listen to music
but guess what mr levito knew i was
crazy so he let me go on stage every
friday after they threw me out
because i went for like two weeks and
one of the kids raised their hand he's
like excuse me padre
how do i know the [ __ ] in this book is
[ __ ] real i giggled and somebody else
giggling through all of us i didn't make
my confirmation i was 29 years old oh
okay i went back to get the holy spirit
put into me because i thought i was
crazy i thought that would help me but
that's a complete difference that was in
my buddhist boulder day that was when i
was because i i don't believe in
organized real religion i'm like i said
i'm a jeet kune do i got the catholics
the buddhists the santorias and the jews
and i put it all together it works you
know what i'm saying so some days so me
some days i got a yamaha gun i gotta cut
the chicken's head off [ __ ] it you gotta
do what the [ __ ] you gotta do
so
on on fridays you had to either walk up
to that thing which was a blast you got
to walk from that school up route three
which is a thousand million cars coming
at you you want the shop right you
shoplifted gun gum
guns gum
then you walked like three blocks and
then there was the the four star diner
which had a tremendous blt one of the
best i've ever had oh those are great
you had the burger place on the corner
you had all these [ __ ] places to go
mingle but you had a blimpy base
and those days the roast beef from
blimpie was trying to look and go to
blimpion and get a roast because gross
beef from suburban looks like rosie's
[ __ ] it's all brown
and [ __ ] the the noodles brown don't
eat rosemary from subway and all that
[ __ ] they shouldn't kill you but in
those days we
we go to [ __ ] sup uh
blimp behind uh 31st in burger land we
blast off a [ __ ] joint we go in there
and they put on oh mama mia mama mia we
giggle we go in and giggle at waitresses
we giggle at people and then we in those
days we used to smoke with a [ __ ]
glass tube
okay somebody had like we used to go to
a headstock or east-west and it was a
glass tube and you rolled the joint you
put the joint in the tube and that was
the card
struck it in like a [ __ ] last [ __ ]
thing and we get hammered no matter what
we were 13 12. sixth grade [ __ ] for
you people like well i'm considering go
[ __ ] yourself this [ __ ] goes deep deep
deep into the mental block anyway
that's my favorite thing is anyway yeah
will you get me on hot and sticky for so
uh we would go to sit in this [ __ ]
catholic [ __ ] thing over there and
and listen to this priest for two hours
talking about the bible you had to do
that for like eight months eighteen
years to turn into a confirmation once
we got thrown out
i had to stay in school until three but
guess what all the boys would go up
there so all the chicks would stay hang
around and on fridays and still listen
to music at one point in the afternoon
this is i've never repeated this in the
podcast okay he will let me go up on in
the front of the class and sing a song
and i would lip-sync my eyes adored you
by frankie valli in the four seasons
that's why when i was in jersey for the
ufc i was standing mario arias called me
from vegas another kid that was in our
class in the sixth grade to tell me that
he was hanging with our sixth grade
teacher mr lovito in vegas holy [ __ ] so
this is how tight we are like this is
something that everybody was in the
veto's class and i still talked to
people who i had with the teacher
kingwell the one he was saying that he
would hit people yeah that's the
[ __ ] that left me back wow he's
the one that left me back for real new
yorker reasons [ __ ] in the seventh
grade that [ __ ] i'll never
forget him but you know what it was a
wake-up call because he was a good
teacher king well you had to read a book
every month i'll never forget that you
had to read a book a month and he gave
you an oral
book exam whoa so you actually had to
read it you had to read it you had to
read it and guess what today i read
because of that [ __ ] guy
he got me into reading like this summer
when you get put into his class in the
7th grade give me three books and say
you gotta read these three [ __ ] books
so when you come back in september the
first week it was what what are they
called book reports oral examination
before we get the [ __ ] out of here
excuse me people
before we get the [ __ ] out of here i
want to show you something i got
yesterday just to
let you know where our heads at well
first off thank you very much for all
the love we got on this [ __ ] podcast
you guys are some bad [ __ ] i
know lee wants to thank you it's
unbelievable everyone who writes to me
on the email and twitter
everyone's so nice so thank you guys so
much you know uh my brother joe rogan
always talks about being positive and
stuff i don't talk about it that much i
just live it and it's uh it's just an
understanding not an understanding what
we're all positive you're gonna have
good and bad days and [ __ ] like that
listen man i get up at five in the
morning i come here for the last two
years i've been on twitter and i get up
at five in the [ __ ] morning i'm with
you people playing i'm smoking with you
through osmosis we're all having a great
time i started doing videos and [ __ ]
joey karates years ago
and it was the weirdest thing man i
would get these i would you know uh at
those days i didn't know much about the
computer and i would [ __ ] shoot a
video with my friend dan
his son's gonna be a year old happy
birthday my man dominic my nephew and uh
we would shoot a video and put it up and
you know you get great video funny
joey's funny whatever
and then
somewhere in the middle of the night i'd
wake up
and i check it all week later then i get
like you fat [ __ ] i hope you die i
couldn't figure out what it was so i
click onto the person's link
and i go to the youtube page and i would
go you know [ __ ] you you [ __ ] i
hope your mother gets hit by a train and
then i realized i'm doing the same thing
he's doing
you know what the [ __ ] is wrong with me
i mean then i understood what people do
they just go from computer to computer
site and they write [ __ ] on people's
thing i never understood it i wasn't
raised with this [ __ ] i was raised belly
to belly i'm a belly belly guy that's
why i don't text i don't do nothing i
want to look at your [ __ ] eyes take
your sunglasses off when i talk to you
that's how i was raised yeah i wasn't
raised with sunglasses with flip-flops
trying to be cool and [ __ ] talk to me
like a [ __ ] man i'm all about [ __ ]
before we become anything directors
comedians superstars podcasted you know
we're [ __ ] men so you should always
have to act like a [ __ ] man that's
the bottom [ __ ] line right so
you know i was raising i gotta say
something i'll say it to your face i
don't [ __ ] say it all so yesterday
after all the [ __ ] we do and all the
philip battle we have we have a great
time this is what i got yesterday sent
to me
he said that to me your [ __ ] worst
nightmare right this is classic hey fat
[ __ ] [ __ ] hack lose a piece of [ __ ]
rogan shine boy [ __ ]
go [ __ ] your dead fat mother hope you
stroke out before that [ __ ] has your
[ __ ] gold kid
can you believe this [ __ ] now
my whole take on this and for you people
let's hunt this [ __ ] down
because he doesn't know i called the
buddy of mine in jersey they got a buddy
in a jersey that loves doing this you
pay them 200 and they trace this in 70
[ __ ] two hours
and then we send two other [ __ ]
gorillas to knock on your [ __ ] door
and let you know what you did now this
guy hit me up before
as uh
something else uh one time and i [ __ ]
shut him down too he he called me a fat
[ __ ] and a speck i mean just you know
but this one here it's the weirdest
thing because whether this guy's 13 or
27
he's got no [ __ ] life
he's got no life he's got no he can't
claim responsibility he can't do nothing
he's got no this guy's gonna be living
behind the [ __ ] shadows all his life
these are the kids that you see walking
around this is the kid that'll go into a
[ __ ] post office and
kill somebody or waste a kid this is how
it starts yeah because
who raised this [ __ ] maggot who
raised this [ __ ] kid a computer razor
computer and tv the computer raised this
[ __ ] idiot because he's been
listening it's not like he downloaded
the podcast he knows my wife's pregnant
he knows my mother died he knows i'm
with rogan this is what he writes it
cracks me up i laugh because i turn
around in my mind that i feel bad for
this dumb [ __ ] i feel bad in the sense
that he has to go through life
living like a [ __ ] mobile and that's
how you so you're supposed to look at it
like if i got that that would destroy me
for days no because you're not supposed
this guy doesn't have to if he knocked
down my door and said that to my face
i'd shake his hands
because at least you had the [ __ ]
balls to do it the [ __ ] honesty and
you know what get your mother on the
phone she did a fine job
she's still [ __ ] you know not hiding
behind a computer but how do you hide
these are the same and i get these on
twitter and and you laugh you sit there
so if you do this by the way let's hunt
this [ __ ] down people because i
know there's some [ __ ] 10 year olds
that can find you they'll find [ __ ]
obama apple 6
gmail.com
i got it working from the other side
when we find you we're gonna [ __ ]
make you [ __ ] write an apology and
i'm gonna go to your hometown i'm gonna
pay a black guy with the biggest dick in
town i'm gonna go to one of those sex
clubs and go i want the biggest blackest
[ __ ] in here with a big pink
[ __ ] helmet one of those mike tyson
[ __ ] where it's so big and black the
black goes pink from black to pink like
a [ __ ] like a [ __ ] scale on a
toaster you know what i'm saying and i'm
going to make you suck his dick
just like that how's that one for you
let's have some [ __ ] fun oh i'm sorry
about talking that way yesterday
somebody sent me a flyer saying you're
invited to an evening of smart comedy
so we're back to that again oh my god
we're so intelligent we're voting for
rodney this smart comedy we're doing at
7 30. jesus and the the thing about that
is
is he definitely knows you yeah he's
probably the type of kid or person
whatever however old he is he probably
goes down he's like alright who do i
follow i'm going to send this to every
single person i follow like a different
one for each person it's very sad i
never understood that i never was raised
to act that way so i don't understand
it's shocks the [ __ ] out of me luke
it takes me and it just rips me apart
inside for two seconds because not
because of what he said his words come
on i've heard fat [ __ ] and [ __ ] mother
all of my life their words bother you
it's just that where the [ __ ] is he
coming from yeah what's he going to do
the rest of his life [ __ ] wear a
[ __ ] dress and high with makeup on
and this is coming from you who's who
robbed trains and did all that bad stuff
you know because i know you gotta look
at a man's eye dog yeah always gonna
look at that's why i don't like texting
what am i gonna text you for i text
somebody when i go with my dick that's a
booty call when you want somebody calls
you calling back this is all part of
being a [ __ ] man this is all part of
being wednesday every [ __ ] day you
gotta act this [ __ ] way these [ __ ]
jerk walls doing this kind of [ __ ] and
i'm like get the [ __ ] out of here lee
tell these [ __ ] what's
happening sunday sunday we have the
biggest show we've ever done we have the
recap of the jon jones finally fighting
we have a preview for sunday football
and monday night football
no monday nights we don't preview monday
nights here because that's a losing
night and my people aren't getting back
the people we run with we're [ __ ]
winning we're winning we lock it up we
go upstairs we get mama stabbing monday
morning wake up and go to work and we
don't got to worry about who's playing
monday am i going to win my money back
[ __ ] no why are you chasing [ __ ]
mondays [ __ ] mondays we do our work like
silent [ __ ] savages we're chasing
your [ __ ] jewels like tupac says on a
sunday so we'll try to make some money
as we can last week i had the under on
the giants the week before that i had
that i had against denver i bet against
denver so i'm 1-1 this week i'm going to
redeem myself with a winner as far as
the ufc like i said dawg it's [ __ ]
wednesday i got to see the weigh-ins but
right now in my heart i really like
melovedes and sometimes your first uh
your first [ __ ] thing is is the other
and i want to go back to what we're
talking about
playing a little bad motor finger for
your [ __ ] uncle joey i gotta get
something to drink real quick i'll be
back [ __ ] all right
[Music]
yeah i wanna get mine
tremendously put the second jam on leigh
come on
what what's the one after that one it's
the album correct no no this is just the
first one let me get let me get the
second one forget it don't worry about
it you didn't get the album this morning
don't worry about it all right brothers
it's [ __ ] wednesday
what else you want to talk about what's
on your [ __ ] mind we got bad motor
thing oh i know what i want to talk to
you [ __ ] about very important
man i be getting all these [ __ ] uh
messages about movies listen i love
movies but i hate this new [ __ ] that
[ __ ] comes up last movie i seen was
the disney one with jennifer gardner and
the [ __ ] kid with the leaf on his
[ __ ] ankle i went to sleep with my
wife and
she cried i got high whatever it doesn't
[ __ ] matter but the other night i was
sitting in a goddamn living room
and all of a sudden death wishes on
right and it's the part where
uh they raped his daughter they raped
his daughter and his [ __ ] wife
and it's jeff goble
so i i'm sitting there like it's nine
o'clock i don't have to be on stage so
10 30.
i might as well watch it i've seen this
movie i mean i seen this in the [ __ ]
movie dude i might as well watch this
i'm [ __ ] sitting and i'm watching
this and i'm getting sucked in we just
sucked in yeah because after you know it
on paper it's a movie about charles
bronson who is the killer's wife no
biggie you know revenge [ __ ] movie
and then he goes on he shoots people
that's what it is on paper that's what i
remember it as
but for some reason when you don't see a
movie for a long [ __ ] time
you
i'll see all these things that you
haven't seen before
you know i watch uh the chinese
connection since i gave it out last week
i watched it the other day and i saw
[ __ ] there's a move when he goes to
fight at the last scene he walks out and
he throws a kick and he turns around
with an elbow i've never seen that move
i've seen i've been watching the chinese
connection since 1971.
it's [ __ ] 12 12 2012 and i just
caught that scene so now i'm watching
death wish the other night and he goes
to arizona and he meets this [ __ ] guy
who was a big character actor in arizona
tucson
and he teaches them how to shoot and
they talk about the service and what he
had done before
and on the way up to the [ __ ] uh
on the way out to the airport you know
he's explained to him he should get a
gun to live in that big bad city yeah
and he's like i don't want no guns
so [ __ ] he puts a gun in his suitcase
oh jesus christ did you know that they
didn't know that you've seen this you've
seen this yeah so i have forgotten all
this [ __ ] you know i forgot about it lee
i mean [ __ ] you got a lot of other
things on your mind
he gets to new york he finds the gun you
know he finds out that the daughter's uh
not going to be the same she's in shock
so it starts hitting him and he takes
the gun to go for a walk one night for
protection because throughout the whole
movie then listen new york city in the
[ __ ] 70s was horrible it was horrible
you have to applaud whoever giuliani
whoever it really was bad if you have a
problem go to uh youtube go to our latin
thing
the first scene and watch one there on
the streets of new york the trash was
everywhere i remember i was a kid even i
don't know riverside drive i lived on
89th street riverside drive with the
jews then i moved to 205 west the a
street with more [ __ ] jews so don't
tell me about my [ __ ] goddamn new
york and they had trash all over the
place and whatnot
so he goes out and some guy comes to
attack him on the side he goes hey man
give me your money and charles bronson
looks at the guy
and he looks straight he's over by like
battery park or something and all of a
sudden he turns around and the guy's
like hey and charles bronson turns with
the gun already pam he shoots the guy
and he runs home he holds on to the gun
he gets home and the weird thing is when
he gets home
remember as a kid or anything he breaks
down
he breaks down he goes on his hands and
knees and he looks at his hands and he
can't believe what he's done he's a real
reaction to what he just did yeah real
reaction like i'm like look at charles
bronson dropping you know knowledge on
the acting department then he was
creating like an archive like i was
[ __ ] really impressed i'm like look
at charles what they did and this is the
dino de laurentiis movie these were
[ __ ] movies charles bronson movies
dino de laurentiis is like spielberg
today you know even bigger dino de
laurentiis walks into a place takes his
dick out everybody's got a sucker even
the bus boy
so [ __ ] uh
it's brilliant you know he starts crying
then you see him watching
you watch him grow as uh
you know it's like anything else he got
the smell of blood he got the taste of
blood you watch him [ __ ] grow as a
vigilante
and now he's shooting [ __ ]
every night he had a cop follow him so
if you get a [ __ ] chance i know that
you guys like joey you're an old [ __ ]
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about movies watch death wish
and watch the yard and what death was
one and two that's which two wasn't bad
jimmy page did the [ __ ] silence
that one's a good one 82 or something
like that i remember i was at the movie
that was a senior in high school and i'm
sitting in front of these [ __ ] women
and the one lady goes oh
look at charles bronson
he's so ugly he's good looking i was
like what the [ __ ] is these freaky
[ __ ] but please you know these
movies from the 70s and 80s sometimes
you're watching a little slow yesterday
i was on imdb for some
and i was watching somebody's list of
movies you know for top comedies i was
shocked by their [ __ ]
predictions or selections but what i
really was you know like they have no
uh planes trains and automobiles on
there and
no and to me if you don't have trains
planes and automobiles and caddyshack on
your comedy list i can't look at it
if you don't have easy money on your
comedy list
you're wrong you know you're just wrong
you're just [ __ ] wrong and be if you
don't have ghostbusters on your comedy
list i can't talk to you if you don't
have stripes on your comments
i cannot talk to you if you don't have
animal house on your comedy list i
cannot talk to you
where do you [ __ ] people make these
[ __ ] lists from have you not watched
the movie you just watched three [ __ ]
movies and make your [ __ ] pitch you
dummies it was hangover on the list oh
please hang over one and two and
everybody's dancing and singing and you
know chinese people with that big side
oh yeah you know but if you don't have
any of these [ __ ] comedy if you don't
have a
woody allen movie as intelligent and
smart and witty as you think you are the
one when he [ __ ] blows the coke when
he goes to go over he goes to snorla and
he blows it out the one with the [ __ ]
house and boulder that they use if you
don't have bullets over [ __ ] broadway
as honorable mention with chaz pomentary
as a mobster with that guy as the writer
i've never seen that oh
oh my god these are [ __ ] comedy gems
these are things that you don't have to
push you know again i read an article on
they're still working on the funniness
of the rest of the i mean how much
[ __ ] writing does this thing need oh
my god they've collaborated you know two
of the funniest writers have
collaborated oh my [ __ ] god and poor
knight michael jordan can't say just do
it one more [ __ ] time just [ __ ] do
it you know yeah yeah
this bio channel from time to time has a
history of a movie okay oh that'll be
great you've seen that like yeah what
happened on the movie and they had
caddyshack on sunday oh jesus and i was
coming back from [ __ ] minneapolis
which guys i still [ __ ] love you tom
bernard you're bad [ __ ] please
support hosta county this weekend my man
uh
i don't know who's there
i'll find out for you
anyway what the [ __ ] was that i also
want to give a shout out to minneapolis
to a cool [ __ ] black dude i met
with a [ __ ] cool sour d i love you to
death i forgot to give you some love
everybody else i met out there we were
smoking out there and that [ __ ]
moment asked me but anyway so yeah you
were talking about the uh the history of
the movie the history of the [ __ ]
movie and they went and they were going
about caddyshack out and caddyshack they
were [ __ ] doing pounds of blow tony
montana was on the set on the [ __ ]
roller skates giving them all blow
so
uh
they had to go down there they had to
stand in the studio down and see what
the [ __ ] they were doing yeah like what
the [ __ ] are you guys doing like you
can't snort for two or three days and
the one guy said if you were on
caddyshack and you remember
you weren't there
because nobody [ __ ] remembers it i
mean those guys are and like bill murray
was the big star of the movie but he was
only coming in brian count but yeah
i just found it yeah it's who you think
you're [ __ ] dealing with by the time
you get the the [ __ ]
by the time you get the name i'll be
next monday you're [ __ ] there what
they still there they still view on
their website who don't view who
the how's the comedy you're still on the
front page like this oh really that's a
singer yeah oh so yeah brian collins
there from when from tonight until uh
saturday so
go enjoy that but yeah i heard the
stories about that especially that scene
with bone murray knocking the flowers
with the golf like that was just improv
and i mean i'm sure the writing was
great for that but it's uh
it's it's kind of like like the music of
the 70s and 80s it really is the voice
music now i watched 16 candles the other
day and i was [ __ ] giggling how can i
look you in the face and tell you i
wasn't giggling with the some dumb young
guy
you know come on guys you [ __ ] giggle
you laugh from your [ __ ] heart you
know i got this movie on dvr that i
adore guys and you're gonna laugh at me
and think i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i
don't give a [ __ ] splash
because you have to see john candy i'm
gonna get [ __ ] emotional when i see
listen guys i didn't go to no [ __ ] uh
i didn't go to the [ __ ] uh improv
olympic i didn't go to no [ __ ] ground
wings and jump up and down with kids and
io which is great for them coming out of
college i learned tom the other [ __ ]
way okay i learned it by watching jackie
gleason you know watch the honeymooners
at night on monday nights by mistake at
the end of the brilliant episode of the
honeymoon was like when he handcuffed
each other with the fake [ __ ] things
look and see how many writers are on
this two there was two jew writers and
jackie [ __ ] gleason jackie gleason
wrote them like like he just was on them
but you watched the end of sign that
live they got 90 [ __ ] writers yeah
what are they giving an hour and a half
two [ __ ] sketches so look at the work
we're doing look where we've been i'm a
pioneer i i watched [ __ ] pioneer ain't
no [ __ ] planet
how about whatever [ __ ] call i always
get high and i forget my words you know
i learned that i'm watching timing from
jackie gleason and
[ __ ] uh you know dick van dyke and
[ __ ] the odd couple and red fox and
samford and son i mean that's what my
comedy balls came from and then i became
a you know i listened to richard pryor
bicentennial [ __ ] and the nigga's
crazy and all three or four george carl
allen's going was the [ __ ] one i
can't remember the one name where i sat
there and wrote it out and i would
practice it in the [ __ ] mirror when i
was you know 12.
the comedy wasn't something that i did
to pick up chicks well comedy was for me
listen i was i got out of prison i was
just getting divorced i was a loser i
had nowhere to [ __ ] go and i figured
i'd i'd kill some time and do some
comedy for a couple years and i was
still crying and next thing you know
what here 30 years [ __ ] later but
that's not the point the point was i was
a student of the [ __ ] game and i
watched it and i give props to anybody
even if i don't like them if somebody
takes me to that next level in comedy
you watch bill you watched uh
what's his name and yeah he's great and
uncle buck and he's a great boy and
[ __ ] he's brilliant at transplanting
an automobile he's opposite steve martin
i mean when steve martin got that call
that day they said you're working
opposite john candy when he hung that
[ __ ] phone down what do you think
went through his head what am i gonna do
against this savage yeah you know you're
going to read the script and go up head
to head with john kane that's never
going to [ __ ] happen so he sat back
and he played this character who they
just jitters together and john he let
john candy do listen when you go up
against guys like john candy uh the guy
from 30 rock the black dude from dirty
rock that the natural [ __ ] people
ain't getting rocked but the best of you
you play a square or you play a uh a
four what's that a defense they play on
michael jordan
when they guard him they let him do what
he does but they [ __ ] guard everybody
else tight yeah that's what you do
against those guys you guard it with
[ __ ] with people like john kennedy
you just let them go they know what
they're doing don't look over their
shoulder and you can see it and splash
and splash
he's so [ __ ] strong with that one
scene at the ball where tom hanks is
definitely goes listen i gotta leave he
goes where are you going he goes i'm
going to cape cod he goes why hang on i
got these two chicks and you you look at
john candy the lighting was brilliant
they made it red and he had a red shirt
on but guys he was [ __ ] up i've been
[ __ ] up on coke and weaving booze a
million times he was buzzing on that
scene and you could see it in his face
and he's like come on over i'm dancing
with these girls and you can see him
shake his little fat body he said we're
going down to rio baby that chick's got
some type of condom and also he goes no
no i'm gonna go find myself i'm in cape
cod
and he looks and he goes really you okay
seriously
because you got enough money
yeah yes can i have some
but the [ __ ] timing
i have it i watch it when i go to an
audition i watch [ __ ] john candy and
he was brilliant so you know before you
[ __ ] make a list make sure john
candies and even if he did a [ __ ]
camera even with all space balls are you
[ __ ] kidding me are you [ __ ]
kidding me you [ __ ] motorized that
hangover with this other oh please don't
get me [ __ ] started more good movie
but they're not [ __ ] classics they're
classics because they're coming out now
and nothing comes out now it's a [ __ ]
classic how many classics you got a year
how many people are going to see these
movies that are coming out 20 years from
now nobody so what the [ __ ] are they
talking about yeah and you brought up
steve martin a couple minutes ago and uh
does that does that kill you when people
came to stop like he's in the he's in a
couple movies but nothing that great and
doesn't do stand up anymore does that
does that kill you or is it just why
does it kill him oh god what the [ __ ]
these people know he he doesn't do
stands i mean he was a [ __ ]
tremendous stand-up he had a [ __ ]
arrow in his head you know he had a
[ __ ] arrow in his head and he quit he
quit i wasn't around for his [ __ ]
stand-up nobody was do you nobody would
what are these kids he didn't nobody was
around when i was a kid i seen my son
life do king tut with the [ __ ] arrow
and he said i don't even know he did
stand up i've never seen him do stan
never even heard of it i watched richard
wright what's his name the guy from
boston do stand up i seen those guys
later on but i was too young for steve
martin nobody remembers [ __ ] steve
martin doing stand up these guys are
walking around like nobody remembers him
i don't remember okay yeah no no no no i
don't know what the [ __ ] happened with
him he was he was one day i seen him do
king cotton the next day he was in the
man with two [ __ ] brains
another classic you know steve martin
all of me yeah are you [ __ ] kidding
me one of my i think my favorite or
close to favorite of his is the jerk oh
please you know this is just guys we
have there are so many movies the
history of the world part one and two
monthly python
guys there's so much [ __ ] you we have
catching up to do but we can't do it all
in one day because it's [ __ ]
wednesday we got [ __ ] to do it's the
church or what's happening now you're
smoking dope you're eating breakfast
you're trying to get healthy what's your
[ __ ] day look like the rest of the
day my days my days looking like work
and then that's it man but uh i'm happy
to be here and this is it's just great
being here with you okay i'm happy you
came over this morning i'm happy for you
[ __ ] for tuning in listen do me
a [ __ ] big favor all right tomorrow
night i'm in madison wisconsin [ __ ]
with duncan
duncan [ __ ] trucks
tickets are 20 dollars they're on
[ __ ] line we're at champs come on by
eight o'clock show friday i'm in
milwaukee wisconsin the home of duke
[ __ ] rufus hopefully we'll get
to see him and we will be in germantown
tickets also are on paypal we're [ __ ]
my brother duncan trustworthy tickets
brown paper tickets i'm sorry next week
we're in [ __ ] baltimore what else we
got going on here brother thank you for
all the [ __ ] love on this podcast i
mean me and lee every day lee we just
giggle it's funny joy joe's really
intense but he'll call me to be like are
we still number one i said yes and it
sounds like he's going to pass it i'm
gonna i can't believe it you [ __ ]
guys uh
we never expected this we just wanted to
try to give you a great podcast and try
the best we can that's all we're not
here to lay claims we're not [ __ ] you
know you know what i'm saying but uh i
love you [ __ ] from the bottom
of my heart i really do that only does
least really starting to get into this
uh we love you i'm sorry if you get
offended today i'm really not [ __ ]
sorry but i'm just saying this
you know the sponsors or whatever thank
you for all the [ __ ] people who are
coming calling us and contacting us with
sponsorship you know i'm gonna run it
but my attorney and we'll get to you
guys next week i'm gonna run by lead and
see which one works best for us so if
you know slow down for a few days
because we got overwhelmed and i'm just
looking at them now and i sense them to
my attorney so thank you very much for
the sponsorship consideration all that
stuff thank you for buying the cds thank
you for coming to the shows hopefully
i'd love to see you [ __ ]
milwaukee i'm going to go down to that
little italian neighborhood where they
had donnie brasco you know donny brasco
arrested people milwaukee it's not in
the movie but if you get the book he
went there to meet with some people and
he arrested a lot of bosses out of the
midwest they have some italian food and
[ __ ] milwaukee in that little
neighborhood where the comedy cafe used
to be i think it's still the comedy cafe
amazing and cheap i got a meatball
sandwich for two dollars 10 years ago
the [ __ ] fat was running down my face
it's another midwest place like
minnesota hey man the [ __ ] midwest
food i'm still counting points lee's
going back to the gym i'm working up
this morning guys have a great [ __ ]
weekend i love you [ __ ] all my
heart today for people who are looking
at this today i will be on the rogan
podcast at three o'clock with the
director from cocaine cowboys oh [ __ ]
i'm bringing my books i'm bringing the
whole [ __ ] thing all right i love you
guys stay black please support that
squad beating the beast duncan joe rogan
give him all love get your alpha brain
sticking in your [ __ ]
[ __ ] rocking and [ __ ] stay black
please give him a kiss [ __ ] bye
guys we've got frankie valley my eyes
are dirty on the way there you go
brother
[Music]
we came to me